good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock it's been dubbed operation save
big dog
the campaign to restore the pm's
credibility but some of his own mps
think it's barking mad some senior
conservatives say plans of a downing
streak clear out and some new policies
don't go far enough we'll speak to the
education secretary nadim zahawi very
shortly indeed it is monday the 17th of
january
synagogue siege two teenagers are
arrested in manchester after a british
man held people hostage in a 10-hour
standoff in texas
down but not out boris johnson looks to
mount a fight back this week in the face
of growing anger over downing street
parties
less time home alone people in england
can now end their coveted isolation
after five days and two negative tests
scene of devastation the red cross warns
of significant damage from a volcanic
eruption on tonga as new zealand and
australia send reconnaissance planes to
the region
no advantage djokovic the world tennis
number one arrives in dubai as the
aussie open begins without the defending
champion
going virtual the chinese president is
among the leaders addressing the world
economic forum as the event is forced to
go online only for the second year
running
[Music]
and i'm at waterloo station where busy
commuters are being cheered up by
volunteers on what's meant to be the
most difficult day of the year for
mental health
there's a social contract that we all
have that if you steal or if i steal
then the person who is the authority
comes in and they fix the situation but
the person who fixes the situation is
killing us
i also had for you how we can win we
speak to the activist and author
campaigning to turn the tide on racial
inequality in the united states
and we're on the trail of the dog
detectives sniffing out sickness we'll
speak to the charity training up poppies
to detect disease that to come
[Music]
let's start though with no let up in the
pressure on the pm as the ferrari over
dining street parties which breach
lockdown rules continues as you can see
joined uh by the education secretary
sahari thank you so much for taking the
time to join us this morning let's just
talk about what happened over in texas
to start with if i may
we believe that it was a british
terrorist uh malik
faisal akram um who was responsible for
that incident two young men arrested in
greater manchester overnight what more
can you tell us well i think the
important thing obviously this is an
ongoing situation uh president biden i
spoke about it being a terrorist
incident i i also think it's an
anti-semitic
incident um it's important that the
police now
um
carry out their inquiries including
obviously anti-terrorism squads uh and
i'm sure the home secretary will say
more about this in due course uh
it's you know the good news is
none of the hostages were harmed they
were all released safely uh but clearly
uh this uh
has
several uh ways to go here in the uk and
it's important that the
police do their work and and terrorism
squads do that work thoroughly to make
sure we understand exactly what happened
what are the networks around
this particular individual um who would
have supported him in
his terrorism act
do we know if he was on the radar for
the security services here in the uk
well i can't obviously comment on an
ongoing investigation okay you'd
understand that what is the um let's
move on to the prime minister what does
he need to do to win back trust because
it's at an all-time low
well i think this is both for me
personal you will remember i lost my
uncle to
covert we couldn't visit him in hospital
we couldn't have a proper burial firm
because of the restrictions and of
course it's very public because i'm
such a state for education i'm part of
the team
that
delivered the vaccines of course and i
think the prime minister understands the
level of hurt um in the country um
for people sacrificed
people
miss loved ones who they can't turn the
clock back on he said it
dispatch box that i wish i could turn
the clock back and go back to that 20th
of may in the garden he spent 25 minutes
um
to what he perceived to be a you know
supporting his staff and encouraging
them and he wishes he hadn't done that
he wishes that he'd said look get back
to your desk because this is wrong i
hope i by the way i say this sincerely i
hope that i watched kirsten's interview
yesterday with sophie rayworth that he
also apologized i think it's only right
yeah i will deal with that of course but
i'm just saying that
we all have a duty uh to do the right
thing i think when the prime minister
has said we've had the apology now we
need the details and sue gray will
take her evidence and conduct her
inquiry and report swiftly and the pms
that he will submit himself back to
parliament uh to a statement and be
questioned on that and i think that's
the right thing to do i think that is
the fair thing to do um so
i hope people will will
allow him
the ability to respond to a thorough
inquiry by a very senior civil servant
reports over the weekend two people have
come forward to say that they personally
warned the prime minister that the email
invitation said that it was a party and
it shouldn't go ahead he says that's not
true why do you believe him
because i think he's absolutely right
when he says
it's not true because i think
ultimately um the
sugray investigation will be able to
look at all that and he's obviously um
submitted himself to that investigation
and sue gray as i know the civil service
and how
they will conduct their inquiry will be
thorough in terms of
looking at emails looking at
correspondence looking at everything
and i think it's important that
she does that but it's not true that the
prime minister knew about this he
implicitly thought this was a work event
he went from i think six
pm to 625 and then back to his desk and
i think it's only right that we wait for
we know the fact that we missed the
harley we know that there were trestle
tables with peanuts and goodness knows
what else we know that there was booze
we know that at the time only two people
could meet socially distanced uh outside
people were literally putting their hand
on glass at
care homes because they couldn't go in
to see their loved ones you know the
prime minister wants us to believe that
he spent 25 minutes having a drink and
thinking it wasn't a party
all i can say to you is i completely
understand how people feel angry about
this i think the prime minister
some pictures from this this was one of
the constituencies over the weekend
people have got lies written all over
not that one the other one i will come
back to that one in just a second this
one they've got lies written all over
their constituency offices
and as i
said to you
that is not the anger and the level of
of hurt is not lost on me or my family
or anyone so i absolutely share that all
i would say is
we have to allow the investigation to
take place why because that's the fair
thing to do you you don't condemn a man
without a thorough investigation i think
sue gray will conduct that and will
report the most famous woman in britain
at the moment isn't she everybody saying
her name what about this this was um
obviously a cartoon in the evening
standard
reflecting on her majesty sitting on her
own the day after the doors were coming
off number 10 people breaking swings
taking a suitcase to get boos um having
a dj in the basement come on and that is
one of the most you know the the
photographic image
was one of the most painful images i
think um that will endure
with all of us with the nation for
anyone who's lost anyone who's lost
loved ones as
the nation's families have done up and
down the country i don't i can
absolutely
say to you that the prime minister feels
the pain which is why he came to
parliament delivered an apology said he
was all he asked afterwards and you say
i didn't really shouldn't really
apologize but sometimes you just got to
do it well that's not
that's here say in reporting that's not
true that's not the prime minister that
that i've spoken to
um someone who i trust implicitly told
me that he'd had that conversation with
the prime minister well
look
if that someone is prepared to come on
your show and talk about it all i can
say to you is i've spoken to the prime
minister and i know
how much
he recognizes the pain and that people
went through and which is why he
apologized and he came forward and said
look i'm sorry um
just allow this investigation to take
place that's all he's asking and then he
will submit himself to parliament um
with a statement to be questioned and
well i wish he misled parliament should
he step down all right well first of all
let's wait for the investigation i think
it's only it's only right here
remember yeah
our british values are all about you
know fairness and you don't condemn an
individual before having all the facts
before you
the the thing that that you you and i
both know that he's apologized and i
hope other politicians do the same thing
when they've actually done something
come on i'll speak to them uh about it
one of the other suggestions that was
made by some of the backbenchers over
the weekend was if the prime minister is
so confident that he's got the support
of his party why doesn't he put himself
up for a vote of confidence and see how
it goes
well first of all
your
prime minister's
that's not how we um you know operations
happened before in well
you say that but the prime minister i
think you know has every right to focus
on the job we've got a big leveling up
agenda we've got a leveling up white
paper which my department has been
contributing to to make sure that you
know things like literacy numeracy
leveling up is all about human capital
and education is they're leveling up
departments so we're doing
tremendous work in that area and you're
going to hear more from me on this
you're going to hear more on the the
what we're doing on the cost of living
4.2 billion pounds to help people with
the cost of living i know it's something
that that you know i think sky and other
channels have been running today the
the the help we're doing
in april you get nine pounds 50 for the
national living wage we're
you know moving the taper for people on
universal credit to help them with the
cost of living
all these things are what the premise is
focused on at the moment that is the
right thing to do and i think it's right
to that he apologized and it's right
that he says look
i will submit myself to parliament once
sue grey is reported with all the facts
and i think you'll find
that
that is the the the way we conduct
ourselves so the week after next i think
is when we're going to hear from her she
can she can obviously she's she's doing
it swiftly of course which is tricky
well the but the civil service as you
know and this is a civil servant the
highest uh you know level of experience
and uh integrity and i think it's only
right that she can take the evidence
wherever it leads and she has everybody
to do that and of course
you talk about leveling up um
the resolution foundation think tank
nine percent of uh people find it
difficult to heat their homes and thus
their kids at the moment that is going
to increase to 27
in april so the energy price cap remains
in place that's important i just spoke
about the uh national living wage going
higher
i don't agree with it's going to be huge
pressure which is why we're putting 4.2
billion pounds of help we're giving half
a billion pounds to local councils who
know those families who know the exact
families who will have problem paying
their utility bills uh the national
living wage going up the taper between
national liberation the taper change on
universal credit that's two thousand
pounds additional help for those most
vulnerable plus of course things like
the warm homes grant and
the winter fuel yes
more than a quarter of homes will still
be struggling to keep people warm it and
it is absolutely under a conservative
which is why we're putting 4.2 billion
to support those most vulnerable
families
but we'll always look at other things
all the time and
and i know my colleagues both in the
treasury and of course in department for
energy are looking at you know how we
can further the best way to mitigate k
is to make sure we have energy security
which is the investment in uh renewables
but not just offshore wind which we're
quadrupling but in nuclear nuclear will
give you that base load
that helps you sort of wean yourself off
hydrocarbons should that mean that 27 of
people will not be in fuel poverty well
we continue to to monitor the situation
closely the reason is shocking isn't it
which is why the energy price cap is so
important which is why national living
wage going up to 9 pounds fifty so
important which is why the half a
billion going to local government is so
important the taper and you see that
into account still 27 of homes will be
struggling and which is why we will
always go further to make sure we do
more for those who are
really finding it challenging on energy
um also a part of operation big dog um
apparently the idea is to turn the
military on desperate refugees in the
channel is that a good idea
well um
it is a good idea that uh there is a
single command and control um and
that includes
not just naval vessels but all other uh
vessels including border force so that
you actually have a coordinated um
operation in terms of these small boats
a really important idea is the
legislation that pretty patel's put put
through parliament to allow us to have
you know
much better way of of dealing with
illegal uh migration because there are
legal routes for migration that's right
you know i'm the son of immigrants we
know of course absolutely so they're
leaving why it's really important it is
really important so there are legal
routes to to to migration but i think
the illegal rules need to be that which
is why the nationality and borders bill
is so important by combining the uh
command and control it will allow border
force to prepare for that bill to be
implemented on the ground so that we can
finally deal with this issue which is
you know clearly challenging there is no
give you the optics of a naval vessel
against a sinking dinghy with uh
desperate refugees from afghanistan who
were left behind after we had to pull
out
well i'm very proud of what we did in
afghanistan yeah we we're not proud of
the
tens of thousands of of people from
afghanistan and actually what we've done
in finding those uh families the other
people education pretty badly it's been
i don't disagree with i think the navy
would always behave responsibly the
important thing is to make sure that
that actually operation is well
coordinated and well commanded
vessels on on refugees surely but but
but you say that as you're sort of
conjuring up imagery as if you know
these pictures
just to go after the illegal uh uh
smugglers who are putting these people's
lives at risk the important thing is to
you well they're not the ones that are
on the boat well
they're the ones we want to capture and
prosecute and work with our you know
french counterparts to make sure that
also happens
including by the way so there are
several um strategies to make sure we
deal with this and
send the message very clearly that this
is not a good route this is putting your
life in danger getting on these dinghies
and it's horrific to see
what happened to those families a lot of
them actually happen to be
kurdish
origin
dying on those dinghies the fault lies
with the smugglers with those with those
criminals we've got to go after them so
the way you do it well the way you do is
is a multi-prong strategy so you've got
your coordination um on the channel
you've got the
nationality and borders bill and
implementing that properly and then
you've got legal routes for migration
which is why we send the right message
that that there are legal routes if you
have a legitimate claim um
to refugee status then there is a legal
way of doing it that's the best way of
doing it because we're going to cut out
those illegal routes
and that's the coordination that we want
to bring on um we're out of time but
just before i let you go um with your
brief are you still confident that the
exams will go ahead yes this year
absolutely no doubt whatsoever despite
so many teachers being off poorly at the
moment very well the good news is
teachers have done phenomenally well i
thank them from the bottom line
including uh those support staff we
couldn't have done the testing and we've
won on secondary schools without support
staff uh actually exams in vocational
have gone ahead in uh this month and uh
colleges have done brilliantly i want to
thank colleges and college principals
for what they've done exams in the
summer are going ahead and we're making
full steam head making sense
we don't know what this virus will do
all i can say to you is we are
witnessing the transition of the virus
from pandemic to endemic and back to the
prime minister on the big calls he
called it right omicron pre-christmas he
said we'll stick to plan b and actually
he had good advice
he had very good advice but but you know
in labor wales and the snp in scotland
actually really closed down the economy
we remained the most open economy in
europe so on the big calls he got it
right we will have exams in the summer
but we will also
very much recognize that those sitting
those exams have had their education
disrupted which is why we're putting
additional guidelines in helpful i have
to let you go i could talk all day to
you thank you very much indeed for
joining us education secretary thank you
uh quick look at what is happening as
far as the front pages are concerned
this morning how is that story playing
out operation deadmeat reads the front
of the eye as senior tories warned that
boris johnson's plan to save himself
does not go far enough
the mirror leads with a similar story
their headline johnson's scapegoats
uh partygate continues on the front of
the daily telegraph this morning as they
say boris johnson faces a critical week
over alleged coveted restrictions
breaches at number 10.
while the express looks at the prime
minister's fightback plan to level up
britain
the guardian says the pm is accused of
attacking bbc to save his own skin
just hearing there from the minister
about what's been happening in texas and
counter-terrorism police have arrested
two teenagers in manchester as part of
the investigation into that siege at a
synagogue
uh the hostage taker has been named by
the fbi as malik faisal akram he was a
british citizen he was shot dead after
taking four people hostage the 44 year
old from blackburn traveled to the
united states on the 2nd of january
some covered rules in the uk are
changing as of today now people who test
positive for covid in england will only
need to isolate for five full days as
long as they test negative on days five
and the morning of day six but some
experts are skeptical suggesting this is
a risky move that is not based on
current scientific evidence
there are also changes in scotland today
this is what it's looking like if a
person's last vaccine dose was more than
four months ago they will need to prove
they're boosted to be considered as
fully vaccinated also large outdoor
events can now resume without distancing
or capacity limits a change that will
see the return of scottish football this
evening
i'm looking at the latest covet data for
you this morning in the last 24 hours 70
924
new cases have been recorded that
excludes the latest number from scotland
another 88 deaths were recorded taking
the number of deaths within 28 days of a
positive test to 151
987
still to come on the programme for you
this morning
prince andrew has been accused of victim
blaming after his lawyers asked for
virginia duprey's mental health records
talking to the author robert hartman
speaking to a campaigner on the pressure
facing menopausal women in the workplace
also coming up tackling omicron we'll be
joined by the world health
organization's special envoy for the
covert 19 response dr david navarro of
course
but before all of that the red cross is
warning that the scale of devastation on
the island nation of tonga after a
volcanic eruption could be immense in
their words
satellite images show saturday's huge
eruption it caused a tsunami with
warnings issued as far away as japan and
hawaii
relief efforts are now underway with
both australia and new zealand sending
surveillance flights to assess the
damage
let's speak to our southeast asia
correspondent siobhan robbins who's
standing by for us this morning hi
siobhan what more do we know
morning k a very precarious time for the
people on tongo as you said this huge
volcano triggered a tsunami over the
weekend and it's still very unclear how
many people have been affected by that
the main reason for that is the fact
that communications are largely down
as you say australia new zealand sending
these surveillance flights to try and
find out how widespread that damage is
but australia's pacific minister has
said that there are widespread um
problems and damage to houses and
buildings
on the nation
when the when the wave went through we
saw videos coming out on saturday
rushing through streets also reports
that a british woman has been swept into
the sea she was walking her dogs on
saturday when those tsunami waves hit
her brother gave us this update
the tsunami
swept them away both of both anger and
james
james was able to hold on to a
tree
uh for quite some period of time
i don't know whether angela was swept
away immediately we just adored her
yeah
yes lovely girl look it's it's 48 hours
i i'm not holding out much hope um
uh i i i i think it'll be a body
recovery uh rather than a
you know sorry body retrieval rather
than finding finding her but i'm you
know hoping
as you can hear a really difficult time
for that family as they wait for news as
i said no confirmed deaths at the moment
but aid agencies are warning up to 80
000 people could have been affected by
this tsunami big concerns around shelter
water as well the fact that ash may have
polluted the local water sources and
we're hoping to get more information
when those surveillance flights by new
zealand and australia return
okay thanks very much siobhan thank you
french police are investigating the
death of a five-year-old british girl
who was killed while skiing in the alps
terrible story the girl was taking part
in a ski lesson with four other children
when an adult collided with her as he
was coming down the mountain a man in
his 40s has been arrested and is being
held on suspicion of manslaughter the
investigation will focus on whether he
was skiing too fast or not paying due
attention to safety
the australian open has begun in
melbourne but without defending men's
champion novak djokovic the world number
one has flown to dubai after losing his
bid to stay in australia judges there
upheld the cancellation of his visa
because of covered rules
japan has condemned north korea after
firing of two suspected ballistic
missiles saying it threatened the peace
and security of the region in less than
two weeks nuclear-armed north korea has
conducted three other missile tests
for the second year the world economic
forum will be online today the chinese
president due to give a special address
later on this morning let's find out
more shall we tom standing by for us in
beijing um hi tom so online again
yeah morning k um they had hoped it
wouldn't be online that things would be
back to normal but this is going to be
an online-only event as you say the town
of davos itself will remain pretty empty
that does suit china's president xi
jinping he hasn't left the country in a
long time state media here call it cloud
diplomacy what he does do is video calls
and this is a good opportunity for him
to put china's case to the world
remember he wasn't allowed to speak at
cop 26 because no one was allowed to
address it via video link and ahead of
the beijing olympics this is a chance to
get back on the international stage i
think the main topic of president xi
speech but also for the whole week of
discussions is going to be about the
post-covert uh recovery and how the
world gets back together we do have some
data on that china released its gdp
figures today they show that had eight
percent growth the highest growth in a
very long time um compared to the year
before which is a very very high number
but there are some slight uh reasons for
concern that growth slowed very sharply
in the second half of the year as they
dealt with regulatory challenges also
dealing with covid still here and the
demographics released show that they've
had their lowest birth rate for a long
time so that will be worrying not just
for china but for the rest of the world
because they have driven so much of
global growth so if china's going to
have problems that could pose problems
for the rest of the countries around the
world coming out of covid okay thanks
tom thanks
is this the saddest day of the year well
according to some it is known as blue
monday the mix of long nights bad
weather post-christmas
apparently leaves us feeling a bit low
frankly well today the nhs and the
samaritans are both launching campaigns
to help people in the uk address mental
health issues ali is down at london's
waterloo station for us this morning
where samaritans are going to be out and
about aren't they what's the plan ali
good morning
morning kay well the plan is to
basically get people to talk about
mental health because it's not really in
a busy commuter station that you'd
expect to be stopped offered a cup of
tea with a smile and a chat but that's
what they're doing to busy commuters
this morning as you say blue monday is
meant to be supposedly the most
difficult day of the year right after
christmas but they want to sort of
reframe that and say that every day of
the year we should be talking about
mental health not just on blue monday i
want to have a quick chat to olivia
who's one of the volunteers morning
olivia how has the response been so far
this morning people been coming and
speaking to you guys yes they have it's
still quite early so we're waiting for
the commuter football to pick up a bit
but we've had some people coming over
asking what this is all about and giving
them a tea bag and telling them to
connect over a couple together and i
want to speak to you about we've got an
artist coming nathan wyburn who was on
britain's got talent and he makes these
amazing art pieces tell me a bit about
this
so nathan has done a special
commissioned piece of work using coffee
and biscuits for our brew monday
campaign
and as you can see the image is about
two people connecting um having a catch
up over a cuppa
and building that chance to talk and
chat thank you so much so he's going to
be here later making a piece of art out
of coffee and speaking to people and
offering them a cup of tea it's all
about talking about mental health openly
and anyone who's in waterloo station
today all stations up and down the
country may well be met with a smile and
a cup of coffee by one of the lovely
samaritans that are here okay well i
think you look even more beautiful this
morning than you normally do and
hopefully that'll cheer you up
okay
as do you
thank you love see you in an hour thank
you
so as we were saying the nhs is
launching a new campaign to encourage
the nation to take better care of their
mental health and they're doing so with
the help of a very famous beatles song
let's take a listen help
i need somebody
help help
not just anybody
help
you yeah we recognize it don't you as
you can see the campaign features some
very famous faces including craig david
and ella henderson the nhs hopes to
encourage anybody experience anxiety or
depression to come forward and see how
talking therapies can help
help we want to reach everyone and ask
them if they're struggling
and by that i mean things like uh
feeling really depressed low mood
sleepless
loss of appetite unable to concentrate
unable to enjoy the things you used to
do
a whole range of common mental health
problems like that
our evidence-based therapies can work
with you to change that so there is hope
um blue monday i'm afraid today stay
with us we're going to cheer you up
throughout the programme we've got
puppies later on first the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
southern parts will be mostly settled
over the next few days with overnight
fog and frost but there'll be some rain
in the north and the west
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
southeastern parts of the us have been
left without power after a storm brought
strong winds and heavy snow
let's take a look at some of the images
that better illustrate that for you this
car struggles through the dangerous
conditions that led to five governors
declaring a state of emergency up to 10
inches of snow fell in some areas of
north carolina and flights were
cancelled across several states 10
inches that's about that isn't it my
goodness let's take a look at some of
the other pictures in the mornings
newspapers i know you like this section
of the program don't you this is the
telegraph wow look at that picture shot
of whitby abbey in north yorkshire um
299 images stacked on top of each other
to create this amazing star trail it was
a full moon wasn't it last night as well
the guardian has a picture of rudy the
spotted bengal cat in the short-haired
cat society show championship
there is held up by his owner wearing a
feline face mask just showing off
gorgeous pussycat the time shows the
students in china practicing a plum
blossom fist it's a routine which is a a
form of kung fu apparently don't try
that at home folks and the bags lady the
mirror shows us a picture of angela
clarke who's entered the record books by
collecting 10 000 plastic bags dating as
far back as
1954. the question that immediately
springs to mind is
why and people in southwest mexico
gather in traditional costume for the
town's grand festival which took place
over the weekend
not sure that would suit me a quick look
at the top stories for you so far this
morning on the program two teenagers
have been arrested in manchester as part
of an investigation into the british man
shot dead after a siege at a synagogue
in texas
the time people in england need to spend
in isolation for contracting covid is
being reduced to five days from today
[Music]
and more pressure on the pm over the
downing street parties rally with many
of his own mps suggesting an overhaul of
dining street culture and new policies
aren't enough to restore his credibility
well within the last half an hour or so
we've been putting some of that to the
education secretary nadim zahawi he told
me the prime minister understands the
hurt caused over the parties during
lockdown
i think the prime minister understands
the level of hurt um in the country um
for people sacrifice
people
miss loved ones who they can't turn the
clock back on he said it
dispatch box that i wish i could turn
the clock back and go back to that 20th
of may in the garden he spent 25 minutes
to what he perceived to be a you know
supporting his staff and encouraging
them and he wishes he hadn't done that
he wishes that he'd said look get back
to your desk because this is wrong i
hope by the way i say this sincerely i
hope that i watched kirsten's interview
yesterday with sophie rayworth that he
also apologizes i think it's only right
yeah i will deal with that of course but
i'm just saying that
we all have a duty uh to do the right
thing i think what the prime minister
said we've had the apology now we need
the details
tamara's here glad to see you got the
navy memo as well this morning uh what
do we make of what the education
secretary had to say it's not going away
this despite what they're trying to do
it's not going away we're not expecting
the sue gray report until probably next
week now
and i think there's a sense that the
mood is hardening among tory mps we now
have six of them on record another one
at the weekend calling for the prime
minister to resign several i've spoken
to say that the mood on the doorsteps is
pretty grim that they're receiving post
bags of 400 or 500 emails that's a lot
being critical of the prime minister
over this but there were no huge
revelations at the weekend and nadine
zaha we thought was interesting he
repeated a denial from number 10
yesterday that the prime minister had
known about the email about this
critical party on the 20th and he said
he believed him when he believes him
when he said that despite some reports
of the weekend that the prime minister
was warned it looked like a party
they're saying he didn't know about it
he didn't see any emails about it so if
that's borne out in sue gray's inquiry i
think downing street will feel pretty
pleased about that in the meantime they
know this is a make or break week
there's a few new policies have been
rushed forward including plans to send
the military to help tackle illegal
migration in the channel plans to freeze
the bbc license fee all of that has come
out today and got some decent coverage
in the conservative supporting
newspapers they'll be hoping to try and
seize back the agenda but of course it
all hinges still for many conservatives
on what is in that report and how
damaging it is feel poverty is going to
be a big problem though it is the cost
of living is going to be a big problem
we have a couple of big reports out
today showing just how many people are
going to be really struggling to heat
their homes struggling to afford to buy
food they know that energy bills which
will be the new price cap will be
announced at the beginning of february
and that's how much we'll pay from april
combined with the tax rise in government
they are pretty clear energy bills are
going to go up by hundreds of pounds in
april whatever support the government
offers and this so if boris johnson
wants to try and seize back the agenda
there are plenty of obstacles in his way
including of course that a lot of people
are going to feel a lot worse off okay
tomorrow for now tomorrow's take at nine
o'clock see that look forward to it
thank you
meantime prince andrew has been accused
of victim blaming after his lawyers
asked for virginity phrase mental health
records the duke of york's lawyers want
to inspect notes from her counselling
sessions after it was suggested she may
suffer from false memories a daily mail
columnist and author of queen of the
world robert hardman is with us now hi
robert um how is this going to look
well good morning kate um
this is the latest stage and what's
going to be a long and torturous legal
process
um i mean
you know we've seen
both sides really um you know deploy
every tool in the box it's what happens
in this sort of
particular civil litigation in the us
and uh and i'd say uh we will we will
see more of it i mean some will um you
know accuse the duke's lawyers of using
particular tactics but um it seems that
you know in an american
civil case you know anything goes as far
as one can see
what do you think the rest of the royal
family are making of all of this
i think they find the whole thing um
utterly uh
distressing regrettable um you know
which it wasn't there
um i think they made that pretty clear
last week with the decision to uh remove
all the military titles and patronages
um from the duke and uh those two words
in the palace statement we saw last week
you know he will fight this case quotes
as a private citizen uh when you're born
hrh when it's your birthright um and you
have those uh those three letters taken
away i mean that's that's really uh you
know even the
edward viii after he advocated didn't
lose or wasn't told to stop using his
hrh so uh you know the family will want
this uh want this out of the way as
quickly as possible but you know the
legal process has to take its course
he'll still be allowed to call himself
prince though will he
still prince still duke of york i mean
that's you know like mr i mean you know
you're born with that and the hrh he
hasn't been some people have said he's
been stripped of it he hasn't been
stripped of it he's agreed not to use it
and so he's effectively in the same boat
as the duke of sussex in the duchess of
sussex again they've they've agreed not
to use the title um because it sort of
it it it
implies it shows a
a royal status um from which he has now
stepped back
what's happening with harry saying that
he wants to pay police officers it's not
how we do things over here is it
uh no as uh as as a former um royal
protection officer ken walters written
in the mail today um you you can't sort
of hire um you know uh
scotland yard when you when you feel the
need uh i mean understandably the prince
is i'm extremely worried about the
security of his family who can blame him
for that he wants to do absolutely the
right thing by them um but it seems that
this uh uh tilling and frame with the
home office has now been going on um for
a while i mean it's not just in the last
few days um and it also um takes us back
to one of the central charges uh from
the um oprah winfrey uh interview which
the new conductors famously did um in
which the uh
they they you may well remember um there
was a sort of question
of of of the family somehow
uh refusing security for them um and
that was tied into the whole issue of
race um but i mean what this actually
underlines is the fact this is really a
matter of the british government it's
under the queen of the royal family this
is this is harry versus pretty patel not
hm
how's
her majesty think coping with all of
this stress 95 years old
well i mean clearly these things are
stressful but uh you know
i've said it before she has seen it all
before i mean she has
lived through um the most extraordinary
upheavals um going right the way back to
childhood abdication and war she's
had all sorts of family dramas i mean
let us not forget uh this we're on the
eve of the platinum jubilee 70 years on
the throne that's never happened before
but uh at the start of her golden
jubilee right at the start she was um
laid low by a appalling tragedy her
sister princess margaret died in
february and just weeks later uh her
mother um died and all through that yeah
there was another trial right nothing on
the scale of this one but there was a
trial hanging over the monarchy in the
form of the trial of the former royal
butler paul burrell all those um
events were happening and yet the queen
didn't miss a single golden jubilee
engagement it was uh an extraordinary
yeah i remember it very well it was a it
was a triumph the queen was very moved
by it so i think there is a sense that
you know there are family matters noises
off they're one thing but my main duty
is to the nation as head of state uh and
that carries on and i think the queen
has over the years she's very good at
compartmentalizing all these issues so
yes it's stressful but it's not going to
make any difference to the way she
approaches her duty as you say at the
age of 95.
great to talk to you robert thank you so
much for taking the time thank you
thanks
new research suggesting women are not
getting enough support in the workplace
when they enter the menopause even
though symptoms
can be quite severe joining us now is
menopause campaigner from the group
menopause support diane danzenbrick
hello to you
and thank you for joining us on the
program looking at the figures almost 20
of women in the uk experiencing
menopausal symptoms so they feel under
pressure to leave their job
yeah exactly so this new research today
from child care provider coral kids is
really interesting because it shows
again how so many women experiencing
perimenopause or menopause
are struggling in the workplace
and there are various reasons for that
including lack of support
why won't women suffering from the
menopause or menopausal symptoms apply
for top jobs according to the fossil
society
yeah so i think very it very much
depends on the individual so menopause
is a very individual situation as with
you know kind of as with anything
whether it's mental health etc um so for
one in four women they'll experience
almost no symptoms at all two in four
will experience symptoms but one in four
will experience what they call
debilitating symptoms um and i think for
those who are experiencing debilitating
symptoms of menopause very often because
if they're experiencing a lack of
support and particularly a lack of
understanding and i think this is what
it all comes down to it comes down to
this lack of understanding of the
complexity of menopause and how
wide-ranging symptoms can be
very often they are either taking a
sideways step in their career and sadly
some are stepping away altogether
yeah i'm very lucky to have christian
and khalid in the studio with me here i
have it so cold as a polar bear in the
corner trying to break the ice because
that's the only way that i can deal with
some menopausal symptoms and that is you
know just in the middle really because
there are as you said a lot of women who
struggle even more one wonders why it is
not a characteristic that is part of the
equality act
yeah and so you know sort of i have to
say since i started campaigning on this
issue and thankfully there are many
people who are raising it now you know
we've seen surveys by the government on
this we're waiting for reports etc we've
got a government appg
last year maria caulfield said that we
would have a task force for menopause
this year so things are moving in the
right direction but it's not happening
quickly enough what we don't need is
rounds and rounds of meetings what we
need is for there to be some action and
this is really quite simple
this all comes down to education none of
us ever learned anything about menopause
so consequently whether we're you know
whoever we are whether we're going to
experience it directly or indirectly
what we need is a greater understanding
and there are now some really good
resources out there
free resources that any organization can
tap into so the cipd have produced some
excellent resources for hr for line
managers for you know business owners um
so that's something that every business
could take a look at today
what many women said was that there was
no forum in the workplace for them to
talk about menopause openly so again
something that every organization could
do today is that they could implement
some kind of menopause um collective
where people could come together to talk
about it because just talking about it
and knowing that you're not the only
person going through it can make a huge
difference
and particularly we do have a for
actually we do have a forum at sky where
where women can get together and and
talk about the menopause and that makes
a big difference um for women of a
certain age actually you can go through
the menopause younger as well of course
um but it's important for younger people
men and women to realize what the
menopause is i call it the power surge
because menopause was really a dirty
word for a long time but i think i think
the tide is turning isn't it
a hundred percent things are definitely
changing you know we are seeing some
organizations doing some excellent work
in this space but what we need is we
need that across the board because
essentially
if somebody steps away from the
workplace before they have reached their
true potential that's tragic that's
tragic for the individual also obviously
can have a financial impact on their
family situation but it's also tragic
for the employer because they're losing
a valuable member of their team
the you know sort of the answers really
are quite simple and it is absolutely a
win-win situation
dan we must leave it there but it's
great to talk to you thanks so much for
taking the time thank you pleasure
thanks kate thanks a lot
as of today people in england who test
positive for coronavirus will only be
required to isolate for five full days
as long as they test negative on the
fifth and the sixth day or certainly the
morning of the sixth day joining us now
is dr david nabarro from the world
health organization hi doctor thank you
for joining us do you um think this is a
good idea
i think that
every government now has to be dealing
with just one
really major challenge and that is an
awful lot of people are
sick with kobe right now
and that means a lot of absenteeism
and so each government has to make a
trade-off which is the greater risk to
have uh further collapse of essential
services like hospitals
and
supermarkets and the like because of
people just being absent for long
periods or shorten the period of absence
accept the risk that some may still be
infectious but the majority won't be at
the end of a shorter period of isolation
and try to keep society going and i
watch these choices being made i
completely understand them and i think
that as long as there is just one thing
done and that is that people are told
that we're still dealing with a virus
about which we know very little and it
may be necessary if we don't get things
right the first time perhaps to adjust
the the instructions and change the
restrictions but right now the plan is
to try to shorten isolation and to see
if that can reduce the absenteeism
problem
and to the other end of the scale doctor
what about long coverage what do we know
about that how do we know whether it's
long covered or whether it's lethargy
and brain fog as a result of of other
ailments or indeed the season
it's been always been a challenge to
work out for certain whether the longer
symptoms that sometimes occur uh during
and after a viral illness
are what some would call a genuine
illness and what others would say is
perhaps something that's uh due to one's
attitude and mood i've always been a
believer that there is such a thing as a
prolonged illness after viruses and
we're seeing exactly that with kovid
long cove it is for real some say it's
one in 20 getting it others say it's
perhaps one in 31 in 40 but whatever it
is and many people do have prolonged
symptoms that can last up to three
months even longer and does omicron give
us the same long covid as other forms of
the virus do my colleagues who work on
long covid say that preliminary signs
suggest that it it is happening so it
just leaves me to say to everybody
this virus is horrible it has so many
effects in so many different ways long
covert is definitely one of them
okay um but for most
of us most people who have had
covid it does
appear from the latest figures at the
end is in sight we're down from 120 000
cases on sunday uh to 81 000 cases
yesterday that in a week down by a third
in the uk
well i mean first things first you know
this is the uk story but really
elsewhere in the world things are
nothing like as promising
we have
many many reports of countries where
health services are overwhelmed because
of illness combination of delta and
omicron so looking at it globally
there's still a long way to go but
looking at it from a uk point of view
yeah there does appear to be light at
the end of the tunnel all i'm saying to
everybody is i think that it's going to
be bumpy before we get to the end so
even though it's possible to start
imagining that the end of the pandemic
is is is not far away
just everybody be ready for the
possibility that there will be more
variations and mutations coming along or
that there will be further challenges
with other surges even of omicron coming
now don't imagine that it's all going to
be fine i know that sounds like i'm a
killjoy i'm trying not to be i'm just
simply sharing my own emotions about
this
um i read over the weekend that more and
more young children are in hospital in
london with covid how do we protect our
little ones of course something close to
you
yes
yeah i mean we talked a lot about my
grandchildren i just found out over the
weekend that in fact one of my
grandchildren a young lad called max
who's is still i mean he's just over one
and he's got covid with his mum and
they've been isolating and it's super
hard to protect children i think this is
just one of the many really troublesome
features about this disease is the
children get it they don't get very ill
but they are perfectly capable of
passing it on and we're going to go on
having children actually acting as the
vectors of the virus for some time to
come and that means of course that there
will be some children who get severely
ill and i noticed as you have that there
are increasing numbers of children in
hospital with some consequences of their
covet i've got nothing unfortunate that
i can say about this as a specific point
but it just helps me make my general
point which is that we should all of us
be still be respectful of this virus do
what you can to stop transmitting it do
what you can to protect others from
being affected by it it's not the common
cold i know people would like it to be
it's a it's a virus that has still some
really unpleasant features let's do our
best to protect people from it if we
possibly can
well we all wish max better with his mum
and hopefully that happens very soon
thank you very much indeed doctor thank
you thank you thanks a lot